uh there's a lot of people on the
conservative right in the main but
basically saying they believe he's been
deliberately targeted and taken down to
silence him because he's been promoting
what they see as conspiracy theories I
mean it certainly seems like that I mean
I think you just you just start to see
the same thing over and over again we're
prominent figures like like the Tate
Brothers right come out and then all of
a sudden they have all these allegations
from 10 years ago and there's no
evidence they don't go to the police and
all of a sudden it's it's believed women
with no evidence
and and it becomes like trial by the
media which I just think is wrong